oh that's tough hey guys welcome to camp
can it's a world of imagination wires
audience is a tech obsessed crowd no
surprise stan winston's schools crowd is
also tech obsessed so we had to pack him
full of tech surprises and in our
earliest meetings we talked about those
there had to be lights there had to be
cameras embedded we talked about
embedding a microphone that would be a
surprise that would come out of a gun
anything we could do to make you go oh
it can do that too one of the nice
things about this project is that it's
Wired magazine like you have to involve
new technology something fun and
exciting we had meetings to talk about
the video the audio the lighting effects
we had to address animatronics we had to
address how do we get this character to
talk how do we get it to interact with
it because that's not normally what we
do concept you're in a live appearance
it's like how cool would it be for this
thing to have sound effects can I crawl
Campion throb that made it seem like it
was alive so they fermius did a lot of
programming in Arduino and came up with
some great sensors that would used on
film but not to the level that we used
it here he created this proximity
infrared sensor system that would
measure the distance between the sensor
and the ground and basically it shoots
out a beam of infrared light and when it
hits something it basically bounces back
into the sensor so
kind of detect where you're at in space
within a limited range
really fun to play with and it's like
some of my highlights of this because
it's like I want to do it on my
Halloween costumes now it's triggered by
what it's actually doing it's not some
random feedback it's it was brilliant
and Alan said put it everywhere
we put motion sensors in Bruce's arms so
that when he moved his elbow it would
trigger a sound effect it added a lot of
life to it you know this is just a
linear pot like a volume control knob
basically it just senses a change in in
resistance and as I stretch it again we
have to balance that with weight and
battery life the technical things you
have to worry about like how long do the
speakers last how long did the batteries
last the powder the Arduino boys are
back up if one of them doesn't work so
you have to balance like how much sound
can I put it it'd be great if we did
this this and then so now I need a sound
mixer or we need two mixers so they get
the first one you know that that's that
balance of part at Commerce on our
seaside Khan had jumped in hard on
creating the actual mechanism that would
be radio control that we move the head
up and down side to side I wanted to use
a particular service I usually use it's
very strong which is sir what's a heavy
so I can't change the servo
but I took a material much as I can so
make it lighter when you do a radio
control you can control the wave the way
the servo motor runs so I create the way
that the two ends it slows down
Oh do this do that but when you have a
different weight control it's sold you
down there
Dave Covarrubias in addition to the
sound started to attack the light the
eyes are the thing that brings its life
this guy will be able to to focus on
work you know work if the body's
attention is over here that so will the
eyes you know he'll be able to lead with
the eyes before you with the head turns
and do all the things that like an
animatronic head would do even though
it's it'll be much simpler I mean it's
just a LED the idea is that when he
starts talking it'll also react to the
boy so we'll have a lot more interaction
that way there's lots of little you know
tricks in there you know to try and get
as much production value as cheaply and
as light as possible the sound and the
lighting almost completed the magic
trick the last piece of that puzzle was
the voice
we have to address how do we get this
character to talk like it needed to live
autonomous and yet at the same time and
had to interact with people in a way
that we don't usually have to do we
don't we don't worry about the voice
that's added in post after the fact but
that's not what was gonna happen here
was all have to be live it had to be
live ad-lib and very very fluid or
organic I can tweak the settings and try
to get something a little just like you
should have a deeper voice boss oh this
is the one you thought was creepy but is
that pitch about the about the right
thing hello-o and it was it was great
people are drawn to that and it helps
sell the ideas like what's happening
there like is that better robot is that
live oh my god there's a guy in there
it's like how's that making noise
putting Bruce in the suit turning on the
lights turning on the sounds and the
voice NDRC head and he was live wait
go get up again
hi there
glad to see you soon oh wow
you really got into this not
really I'm scared
Oh